c'est l'iscid du faux plafond qu'on a
senti au départ l'odeur de plastique
brûlé
donc il venait finalement d'une
surchauffe d'une partie du système
électrique
plongée dans le noir un tiers des
collections du musée du berry aurait pu
prendre feu le 20 mai dernier
un court circuit est découvert dans la
réserve par un agent l'électricité a
depuis été coupée c'était un bâtiment en
structures métalliques et les pompiers
ont été très clairs dans avec ce type de
bâtiment ils n'interviennent pas parce
que c'est le risque d'embrasement
complet trop important et donc ils se
contentent de sécuriser les alentours et
il est se brûler le reste cet hôtel
particulier abrite le musée depuis la
fin du 19e siècle
problème le bâtiment n'est plus adapté à
l'accueil du public
alertés par la préfecture le maire avait
programmé des travaux pour le mois
d'octobre
mais les 50000 euros prévus pour la
remise aux normes de l'électricité ne
seront finalement pas suffisant
de toute façon nous allons prendre le
temps déjà
de voir un petit peu de faire un vrai
diagnostic par rapport aux coûts parce
que c'est quand même important de savoir
où on va et puis
bon pour avoir une réflexion aussi par
rapport au devenir de venir du lieu et
au devenir des musées à bourges c'était
l'un des musées phares parmi les quatre
de bourges le musée du berry a accueilli
quinze mille visiteurs par an je trouve
ça très dommage c'est vraiment un très
beau bâtiment il faudrait essayer de
trouver des fonds pour justement éviter
cette fermeture c'est que je visite est
souvent quand j'étais petit et puis les
salariés du musée devrait être bientôt
réparties sur d'autres sites de la ville
et la municipalité étudie la possibilité
de re localiser les oeuvres dans un
autre bâtiment l'hôtel dieu fait partie
des pistes à l'étude
les oeuvres seront en attendant exposées
dans les autres musées de la ville